HERE TODAY, HARRIS FAULKNER,
KAYLEIGH McENANY, HOST OF
"KENNEDY" ON FOX BUSINESS,
KENNEDY AND IN THE VIRTUAL
CENTER SEE, KARL ROVE.
EMAILS FIRST REPORTED BY
"THE NEW YORK POST" SHOWED
FREQUENT COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND TOP OFFICIALS JUST
DAYS BEFORE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION RELEASED AT
SCHOOL REOPENING GUIDELINES.
IN ONE EMAIL A TEACHERS UNION
OFFICIAL RIGHTS IT WOULD BE
GREAT TO SEE THE INSERTION OF
THE VARIATION OF THE FOLLOWING.
IN THE EVENT OF HIGH COMMUNITY
TRANSMISSION RESULTS, A NEW
UPDATE TO THESE GUIDELINES MAY
BE NECESSARY.
IN AT LEAST TWO INSTANCES,
LANGUAGE SUGGESTIONS OFFERED BY
THE UNION WERE REPORTEDLY
ADOPTED NEARLY VERBATIM INTO THE
FINAL TEXT OF THE CDC DOCUMENT.
THE AFT IN A STATEMENT TO
FOX NEWS SAYING THE AFT
REPRESENTS THE 1.7 MILLION
EDUCATORS, HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS AND PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES WHO SPENT THE LAST 14
MONTHS SERVING ON THE FRONT FRON
LINES OF THE COVID-19 PANDEMIC.
SO NATURALLY WE’VE BEEN IN
REGULAR TOUCH WITH THE AGENCY’S
SETTING POLICY THAT AFFECTS
THEIR WORK AND LIVES INCLUDING
THE CDC THEY HAD IN FACT, WE
CONTACTED THE AGENCY MORE IN
2020 DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND WE HAD DURING
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IN
2021."
BUT THE REPUBLICANS SAY THE
REPORTS SHOW THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS PUTTING
POLITICS AHEAD OF SCIENCE BY
CONSULTING ONE OF THE LARGEST
DONOR GROUPS.
HERE IS SENATOR TOM COTTON A
SHORT TIME AGO.
>> WE SHOULDN’T HAVE A
POLITICIZED PUBLIC HEALTH
BUREAUCRACY LIKE THE CDC
ANSWERING AT THE BECK AND CALL
OF THE TEACHERS UNIONS, WE NEED
KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL AND BACK IN
REAL SCHOOL, NOT SITTING IN THE
CLASSROOM DOING A ZOOM SESSION
WITH TEACHERS WHO ARE NOT IN THE
CLASSROOM, WE NEED KIDS IN
SCHOOLS WITH THEIR TEACHERS NOW.
>> Emily: KARL, WELCOME TO YOU
AND I LIKE TO EAT YOUR THOUGHTS
ON THIS TO BEGIN WITH, AND
EMAILS THAT HAVE NOW BEEN
PUBLISHED, WE KNOW THAT THE AFT
CALLED THE CDC A "THOUGHT
PARTNER AND THAT IN THOSE EMAILS
EXPRESSED THAT THEY WERE
GRATEFUL FOR THE CDC’S "GENUINE
DESIRE TO EARN THEIR CONFIDENCE"
AND THAT IT BEGS THE QUESTION
WHETHER COMPETENCE MEANS
DONATIONS.
THE AFC AND ITS AFFILIATES HAVE
LONG BEEN ONE OF THE MOST
RELIABLE AND DEEP-POCKETED DONOR
CONSTITUENCIES OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, UP TO ALMOST
$20 MILLION IN DONATIONS IN THE
2020 ELECTION CYCLE, IN FACT THE
AFT IS RANKED 27TH 27TH OUT OF 2
AND CONTRIBUTORS.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> LET’S COME BACK TO THE MONEY
QUESTION.
I THOUGHT IT WAS DISINGENUOUS,
HOW THE AFT RESPONDED.
THEY ARE SAYING, FIRST OF ALL,
WE TALKED MORE TO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IN 2020 THEN WE
TALKED OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IN 2021, MAYBE
THAT’S BECAUSE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WAS IN CHARGE OF
THIS COVID ISSUE FROM
FEBRUARY 2020 THROUGH
JANUARY THE 20TH OF 2021 AND
JOE BIDEN HAS ONLY BEEN IN
CHARGE OF THIS FROM JANUARY 20TH
THROUGH TODAY.
SO THERE’S A LOT MORE TIME THAT
THEY WILL BE TALKING TO THE CDC
AND THE SECOND AND MORE
IMPORTANT POINT TO MY
PERSPECTIVE AS THIS, IT’S NOT
JUST THE CDC THEY ARE TALKING
TO, THEY HAVE THE WHITE HOUSE
INCLUDED IN THESE EMAILS,
INCLUDING THE OFFICE OF PUBLIC
LIAISON.
WHEN I WAS IN THE WHITE HOUSE I
WAS IN CHARGE OF THAT OFFICE,
THAT’S YOUR OUTREACH GROUP, THAT
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE TALKING TO
YOUR ALLIES OUT THERE TO TRY TO
ADVANCE YOUR AGENDA SO LET’S NOT
KID OURSELVES, THIS IS NOT THE
TEACHERS UNION TALKING TO SOME
CAREER GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEE AT
THE CDC, THEY ARE INCLUDING THE
BIDEN WHITE HOUSE IN THESE
DISCUSSIONS, SUBTLY SENDING THE
MESSAGE OF THE CDC, HEY, WE’VE
GOT FRIENDS AT
1600 PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE, YOU
BETTER BE DOING WHAT WE SUGGEST,
LAYING THE PREDICATE FOR US TO
HAVE MORE SCHOOLS THAT ARE NOT
HOLDING IN PERSON, IN CLASSROOM
INSTRUCTION SO I THOUGHT THAT
WAS A PARTICULAR MOVE AND YOU’LL
NOTICE THEY GLOSSED OVER IT,
THEY WERE JUST TALKING TO THE
CDC, THEY WERE TALKING TO THE
WHITE HOUSE AND USING
WHITE HOUSE LEVERAGE TO GET FROM
THE CDC WHAT THEY WANTED.
>> Emily: THAT’S EXACTLY
RIGHT, KAYLEIGH AND WHEN PRESSED
BY JAKE TAPPER, HE SAID MULTIPLE
TIMES, CAN YOU POINT FOR ANY
SCIENTIFIC REASON FOR STUDENTS
IN THE UNITED STATES NOT TO
RETURN TO IN PERSON CLASSES
TOMORROW?
HE COULD NOT OR WOULD NOT OFFER
ADVICE FOR AN EXPLANATION.
>> Kayleigh: RIGHT, BECAUSE
THERE WASN’T A SCIENTIFIC
REASON, THERE WAS A POLITICAL
REASON AND IT WAS THE INFLUENCE
OF THE TEACHERS UNIONS.
I THOUGHT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION FOLLOWS THE
SCIENCE, THEY PASSIONATELY
PROCLAIMED THAT BUT IN FACT THEY
HAVE THE TEACHERS UNION
DICTATING THE SCIENCE, THIS IS
EXTRAORDINARY AND I THINK THIS
IS A HUGE CANDLE, WE KNEW BACK
IN JULY WHEN I STOOD AT THE
WHITE HOUSE PODIUM THAT SCHOOLS
SHOULD BE REOPENED, DATA SHOWED
US THAT, I SET UP MULTIPLE TIMES
AS DID PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
OTHERS AND HERE WE ARE DOWN THE
ROAD, THE TEACHERS UNION IS
REVIEWING GUIDANCE, THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE GOT TO REVIEW THE
GUIDANCE THEY ARE AT THE CDC
BEFORE IT CAME OUT, IF YOU
LISTEN VERY CAREFULLY TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND HIS WORDS,
HE WILL SAY, WE SHOULD PROBABLY
REOPEN SCHOOLS IN THE FALL, HE
SAID THAT AS RECENTLY AS LAST
WEEK EVEN THOUGH EVERY TEACHER
WILL HAVE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BE FULLY VACCINATED AND OLDER
CHILDREN OVER THE AGE OF 16 AS
WELL.
IT IS INCREDIBLE AND
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTS HERE
FALLING ON YOUNG WORKING MOMS,
WE SAW "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
OP-ED TODAY, THE BIGGEST GENDER
ISSUE OF OUR TIME WILL BE
WORKING MOMS WHO CANNOT GO BACK
TO WORK WHO HAVE YOUNG CHILDREN
AND ARE FORCED TO STAY HOME,
THEY ARE GOING BACK TO THE
WORKFORCE AT A MUCH LOWER RATE
THAN MEN AND PRESIDENT BIDEN YOU
ARE DIRECTLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
THAT NUMBER AND INEQUALITY GAP
WE ARE SEEING.
>> Emily: AS
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" POSTED, THE
BIGGEST ISSUE OF GENDER EQUALITY
IN 2021 MAY WELL BE WHETHER
POOLS RETURNED TO NEAR NORMAL IN
THE FALL.
>> Kennedy: YEAH, AND THAT IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR YOUNGER
CHILDREN IN PRESCHOOL AND
OBVIOUSLY PRESCHOOLS ARE NOT
BEHOLDEN BY AND LARGE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND, YOU
KNOW, THEY HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING
SOME OF THIS GUIDANCE AS WELL
AND THEY’VE BEEN VERY
SPORADICALLY OPENING AND SERVING
FAMILIES AND WHEN IT COMES TO
FAMILIES YOU DON’T HEAR ABOUT
LEARNING, YOU DON’T HEAR ABOUT
PARENTS, PARENTS ARE LEFT
COMPLETELY OUT OF THESE
DISCUSSIONS, IT’S REALLY JUST
ABOUT THIS MASSIVE POWER GRAB
FROM THE UNION AND HERE THEY ARE
WRITING THE LANGUAGE FOR THE CDC
GETTING INSERTED INTO THE
RECOMMENDATION SO HOW
INSTRUMENTAL WAS THE AFT IN
WRITING SOME OF THE COVID RELIEF
LEGISLATION THAT GAVE SCHOOLS
$130 BILLION, UP TO $200 BILLION
THAT YOU KNOW, MOST OF IT
DOESN’T EVEN GET TO THE SCHOOLS
FOR ANOTHER THREE YEARS.
SO YES, THEY DONATED $20 MILLION
TO DEMOCRATIC CAMPAIGNS IN 2020
AND THAT SO THEY CAN LOOK OVER
POLITICIAN’S SHOULDERS AND WRITE
THIS LEGISLATION FOR THEM SO IT
BENEFITS THEM AND WHEN I SAY
THEM I MEAN THE TEACHERS UNIONS,
I DON’T MEAN THE TEACHERS, IT’S
NOT STUDENTS, IT’S NOT THOSE
THAT ARE IN MOST NEEDS FOR
SERVICES ARE VETTED IN SCHOOLS,
MENTAL HEALTH AND SOME OF THE
FOOD SUPPLEMENTATION THAT IS
GIVEN TO THEM ON A DAILY BASIS
FROM THESE PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO ARE
COMPLETELY LEFT OUT IN THE COLD
ESPECIALLY MIDDLE SCHOOLERS AND
HIGH SCHOOLERS, THEY DON’T CARE
IF THEY EVER COME BACK, FRANKLY.
>> Emily: AND KARL, WE SEE
THAT DIRECT INFLUENCE ON
LEGISLATION, EVEN WITH THE
GREATER NEW YORK HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION, WRITING THAT
IMMUNITY CLAUSE FOR THEMSELVES
THAT MADE IT INTO NEW YORK’S
BUDGET SO BACK TO THE
WHITE HOUSE, HOW IS IT POSSIBLE
FOR THEM TO MAINTAIN WITH A
STRAIGHT FACE THAT THEY ARE
IMPERVIOUS TO POLITICAL
INFLUENCE AND ONLY FOLLOWING THE
SCIENCE WHEN HERE NOW IT IS LAID
OUT IN BLACK-AND-WHITE BEFORE
OUR EYES?
>> Karl: WELL, KENNEDY TOUCHED
ON IT, THE AMERICAN FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS IS ONE OF THE MOST
POWERFUL AND GENEROUS POLITICAL
GIVERS AS YOU POINTED OUT, THEY
GAVE $19,903,000 IN POLITICAL
CONTRIBUTIONS IN THE 2020
ELECTION CYCLE OF VIRTUALLY ALL
OF IT TO DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES,
VIRTUALLY ALL OF IT, JUST A
HANDFUL TO REPUBLICANS, THINK
ABOUT THIS.
IF THE SCHOOL FUNDING IN THE
COVID RELIEF BILL, NOT THE
MEASURES THAT GOT PASSED LAST
YEAR, THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
STRAIGHT PARTY LINE VOTE,
$129 MILLION INTO PUBLIC
EDUCATION FUNDING, FOR EVERY
DOLLAR IN CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS
THEY GOT $6,481.26 IN COVID
RELIEF MONEY.
WHY IS THAT IMPORTANT?
THE CDC IN DECEMBER SAID WE NEED
TO REMEDIATE THE EFFECTS OF
COVID IN ALL OF OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS UP TO $422 PER EACH ONE
OF THE 50 MILLION PLUS STUDENTS
IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS WHICH WAS
ROUGHLY THEN $21 BILLION AND
THAT’S ASSUMING THAT YOU
REMEDIATED THE ENTIRE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM IN SCHOOLS
WHICH TURNS OUT TO BE FAR MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN REMEDIATING THE
CLASSROOMS THEMSELVES AND
PROTECTING THE STUDENTS ALL THEY
REALLY NEEDED WAS $21 MILLION
AND KENNEDY IS RIGHT, VERY
LITTLE OF THAT MONEY GETS SPENT
THIS YEAR OUT OF THE COVID
RELIEF BILL, THE REMEDIATION
MONEY GETS SPENT, THE REST OF IT
GETS SPENT OVER THE NEXT DECADE,
MORE MONEY IS SPENT IN THE LAST
SIX YEARS OF THE DECADE THAT IS
BEING SPENT THIS YEAR IN
EDUCATION INCLUDING THE
REMEDIATION EFFORTS SO THIS IS A
BIG, GIANT, EXPENSIVE GIFT TO
THE TEACHERS UNION AND THEY GOT
IT IN PART BECAUSE THEY GAVE A
LOT OF POLITICAL MONEY AND
PROVIDE A LOT OF POLITICAL
MUSCLE TO DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES,
IT’S NOT PRETTY, IMAGINE WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN, FILL IN THE BLANK
IF YOU DID THAT FOR A REPUBLICAN
GROUP THAT CAME FORWARD WITH
MONEY, YOU CAN IMAGINE WHAT THE
HEADLINES WOULD BE IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" FOR
"THE NEW YORK TIMES"."
>> Harris: WELL, KARL ROVE,
I’M GOING TO GET IN A QUICK WORD
ON THAT END I THINK WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE TO WHAT’S HAPPENING WITH
GOVERNOR CUOMO THAT’S BREAKING
RIGHT NOW ABOUT THE THOUGHT OF
THAT BEING IN THE LAST SIX
YEARS, THAT SPENDING, THAT WOULD
MEAN THE CHILDREN WHO REALLY
PAID THE HIGHEST PRICED
EDUCATIONALLY THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC, SOME OF THEM WON’T
EVEN BE IN SCHOOL STILL, RIGHT?
THEY WILL BE IN MIDDLE SCHOOL
AND HIGH SCHOOL GRADES AND THEY
WON’T EVEN GET TO BENEFIT FROM
THAT.
>> Karl: THE BIGGEST BENEFIT
TO THESE CHILDREN IS TO GET THEM
BACK IN THE CLASSROOM AND THE
SCHOOLS OF THOUGHT BUDGETS FOR
THAT, THEY’VE GOT THEIR ANNUAL
BUDGETS, GET THEM BACK IN THE
CLASSROOM AND THAT TO ME IS JUST
AMAZING THAT THE TEACHERS UNION
IS TRYING TO FIND YET ANOTHER
EXCUSE TO KEEP A GENERATION OF
OUR YOUNG CHILDREN FROM LEARNING
AS A DAY SHOWED AND REACHING THE
GOALS THAT THEY NEED IN ORDER TO
HAVE A SUCCESSFUL LIFE, WHAT IS
GOING TO HAPPEN TO THIS LAST
YEAR?
THEY WANT TO TURN IT INTO MORE
THAN A LOST YEAR.
>> Harris: IT’S LIKE
SENATOR COTTON SAID IN ME, WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT HOW THE
TEACHERS UNION BASICALLY JUST